hey YouTube travelled us back in time to
2006 for a live viewing party of an
inconvenient truth any biased glass is
off watching it not moment in time to
see if it holds up do you know what
happens if a polar bear is nowhere near
an ice cap he turns over and floats the
hurricane frequency rate is precisely
the 100 year average a lot of people
will say hey isn't part of the
scientific method to be critical and to
test some of these high pot don't know
that's junk silent 2018 search this
right now record snowfall cones are but
if not junk science is a home Polaroid
of kilimanjaro in June weather isn't
climate right how often are we told that
now but you're saying that happened
before any of us were here right so
wouldn't that suggest that that kind of
warming can happen without us
definitively this is wrong we know it's
wrong but he painted a picture that ice
everywhere was going away right is this
is this the curtain the air wave is this
the El Nino effect or is this just your
private air travel roof